hallo mein name ist luca und ich hab mir
gedacht ich beantworte wieder ein paar
die salatblätter ich beantworte heute
wieder ein paar fragen die e-mail
twitter gestellt habt da ich nicht die
gleiche perspektive wie im letzten video
haben möchte habe ich gedacht ich
erinnert die mal ein bisschen so und ich
hoffe das geht so klar nein wir fangen
jetzt endlich an mit den fakten fragen
also denke ich mir echt mögt ihr mich
eigentlich bitte lass mich einfach in
ruhe auslagen oder so tue als ich die
frage richtig verstanden haben soll
aber da muss man kurz anschauen twelsiek
in slate ja ich möchte definitiv später
im ausland leben der plan ist derzeit
aber der verändert sich bei mir jeden
tag eigentlich ich möchte mein studium
fertig machen
dann habe ich ein bachelor das ist mitte
2017 und danach möchte ich unglaublich
gern nach london ziehen sich die stadt
über alles liebe alle die mein buch
gekauft bzw gelesen haben haben
vielleicht auch den etwas privatanteil
gelesen wo ich gesagt hab was meine
lieblingsstelle sind und wo ich
unbedingt gerne mal hin möchte wo ich
hin ziehen möchte
und da steht halt london auf der
kompletten ein ich weiß nicht ich finde
die stadt hat einen unglaublichen charme
und also ich liebe london london
übrigens tommy dass die videoclips am
ende man so ein bisschen abgeschnitten
sind aber wird er macht das irgendwie
automatisch
ich werde nicht zu jedem teil ein
autogramm beilegen weil ich sonst nur am
noch am ort beschreibt wäre aber ich
werde mich kurz vorm release mal
hinsetzen und irgendwie 300 400 sachen
unterschreiben die zu jedem rudi oder zu
ihrem shirt oder so beilegen und dann
kriegt ihr dann autogramm bei ich nehme
auf können von ihrem schloss geht doch
also ja es werden bei einigen sachen
autogramme dabei seien allerdings denke
ich nur bei den ersten 300 400 500
vielleicht welche dass man noch mal
irgendwann nach weihnachten machen und
auch vor weihnachten ich weiß nicht wie
viel zeit ich da habe aber es ist jeden
teilten das bka dazu kommen dadurch ein
bild bei twitter gepostet wie das ganze
aussehen wird das wird grundsätzlich
immer dabei seien nicht nur bei den
ersten 500 euro so dass keine
autogrammkarten habe werde ich auf diese
sticker dann einfach bei den ersten 300
400 500 sachen halt einfach auf den
sticker drauf eine unterschrift
draufsetzen
also ja jede jahreszeit erstellen so ein
gewisses etwas so herbstspaziergang
wetter winter ist so drin sitzen und
drinsitzen entweder kann man echt mega
tolle sachen machen man kann drinsitzen
nein ich mag wenn da nicht hallo mein
name ist okay und ich wollte dich fragen
wenn du ein superheld wärst würdest du
heißen und was wäre deine superkraft ich
würde es liebt man heißen und meine
kraft wäre dass ich keinen schlaf
bräuchte schon die zweite frage zum
merchandise ist aber von den ganzen
tagen die ankommen war halt lokal
drittel einfach nur zu den sachen die am
ersten zwölf von mir raus kommen da kann
ich auch nix für letztendlich ist solch
überlassen ob ihr euch die sachen kauft
weil die preise tatsächlich ein bisschen
höher sind als bei anderen youtuber mit
ihrem merchandiser aber das liegt
einfach daran weil die qualität hat echt
nice ist meine mutter wäscht ja immer
noch teilweise meine sache wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise jetzt hier gerade
zu hause bin und da hatte wir jetzt in
der wäscherei rudi und schon zwei teile
aus dem shop aus meinem neuen luca -
shop.de
sie hat mir richtig beiden sachen
eingehalten und schmeißt du das konnten
einfach weg und das andere so locker das
ist gut ich denke dass die preise für
den pullover und dem studio auf jeden
fall unter 40 euro liegen werden ich
weiß nicht so an die 40 euro und die
beiden shops die kommen werden die drei
shirts in weiß ich nicht ich weiß es
schon euch hat ihn nie vergessen werdet
ihr dann ja noch am ersten zwölf und
erfahren alles gut wieso fliegt da oben
wieso fliegender düsenjets land das
winzige risse ich habe gestern
chinesisch essen bestellt das abgeholt
und wer so einen laden rein und dann
stand da schon mädchen bist du locker
ließe ja ich bin luca ich hab mir grad
essen bestellen diese ag2r frage das war
witzig bei jukic gut ja die nächste
frage ist
korrekt danke für diese tolle frage ich
bin tatsächlich recht häufig in dortmund
weil ihr da ja dieses tier galerie ist
das in dortmund ich fahre halt direkt an
dortmund vorbei an eine autobahn und
einige freunde von mir studieren noch in
dortmund deswegen bin ich da tatsächlich
schon so ein mal im jahr
andere leute machen das ja dass sie dann
trio ich flieg der ziel hin unter par
jetzt dahin aber wenn mir was teilweise
so als ich das gemacht hatte dass dann
leute dahin gekommen sind und dann waren
das rostocker mäßige leute und das war
nicht so cool aber die frage zu
beantworten ja ich komme bestimmt noch
mal nach dortmund das war meine reaktion
mégane als man danke und was hast du
denn noch du gehst du hin und rückflug
die letzte sache die mir zu gesendet
wurde ist diese frage
das kann ich dann wenn müll ein
meisterkurs
das war es mit diesem video freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann